to be able to hear me hopefully
king is on his way he's having issues
uh so hopefully those get resolved here
soon
what's going on chat
let me
switch this over
to the wireless headset so you guys can
hear
[Music]
there we go all right so oh yeah guys i
will be doing a unboxing and review
on this little beast
it's the new core elite controller shout
out to microsoft for sending iop one
you know so we can give you guys our
honest opinion
hold up
yeah there
see i need like auto blur or something
see i'm horrible at this
there we go you guys see it
let me check on king see where king is
security
he can come in there's no issues
[Music]
have an issue
all right this is the only other way i
could think of doing it hold up
me
you weren't going to say hello where you
can
all right there's cognito so it worked
fine for him
what's going on i think it again
where to stream it
was going on
[Music]
give me a second
what's
what's going on
even though this look like cg
[Music]
they got that take it off the rim
it look like cg like crazy
you know i i need to know about the
energy ball
can you try to send king an invite too
cause like it's just not working for me
i got you all detected to attack your
john crazy
it's official tekken 8 is coming to the
playstation 5 console courtesy of our
battle hardened friends at bandai namco
entertainment
second eight now stay tuned
okay
just send it to me on the safe side
it would be interesting
was it because they couldn't get street
fighter they go for attack
y'all gonna learn today about this
taking me
i don't take it before i agree
you want to okay okay
i think they said this is 20 minutes
long
okay resolution
oh dude
oh demio coming to the playstation vr
wait wait wait you ahead of me yeah what
the hell yeah demio wait how are you
seeing it yet how are you seeing it all
right
good for them man good for them there we
go let's go baby
this is a good game this is a good game
playstation smart to grab let's go
i told xbox stop playing
i told them
dude this is a good game chad this is
[Music]
i don't think he realized i'm watching
it i would love a
okay okay it makes sense it makes sense
to miss it you'll go to the digital vr
platform that makes sense
i thought they was doing the console why
did they flip is sega publishing
that
oh
god go ahead divya get your bag baby
alone
what's the samurai work
oh
all right you're gonna see what it do
though
it's good man it's a good game dude
this
oh real god
let's go it's like you're closing
peoples
what's this what's this
unless they have a turret
wait is that
[Music]
this kind of gives me away the samurai
vibes actually i might mess with oh
they got the over the top a little
action
like like a dragon each
what's this
what's going on
they're really hitting hard man today's
been a good day for gaming like
he's staying outside
trying to keep track of king
hello madam mason
oh harry potter
he said that was the girl's brother from
two miss quite cheap
warner brother game couch
this is the home harry potter
why is your mistress selling the shop
she has had rotten bad luck you know
this show will be ruined it's not the
delay for ragnarok
he said he's restarting his pc
send it send it like the email i did
i sent him three emails
when he resets we'll see
okay
yes i sent it to that one
all right let me try to send him again
okay
you look tell them that on the facebook
link immediately
[Applause]
wait is this um
it sounds like is it what you call it
had this type of intro the xbox game
that didn't come out by ukraine
he got it he got it
all right there you go there you go
what happened to enjoy
sony sony was trying to stop me from you
shoot yo your mic man low again it's low
right now yeah
um
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that is that
it started like stalking that was so
weird
the great adventures of the old school
station wagon
i got an ad at the bottom of my screen
i don't
it won't even let me get rid of it
it's such an intrusive ad yeah it's so
interesting why don't you you can't
maximize your screen is like half
no that's just how twitch is
you could full screen
no it was full screen
interesting
caller pacific
[Music]
yeah just go over it because you could
go in that right hand corner see that
refresh
yeah and then up like little see that
little xbox i mean a little um four
quarter quadrant box yeah see it in the
right corner yeah hit that hit that
survivor
[Music]
i really got to get artwork made for
these reactions hi everyone i'm grace
chen
not long ago we announced our brand new
loyalty program called playstation stars
it's designed to celebrate you the
players it will be free to join
playstation stars as a member you can
complete various you're really looking
for points that can be redeemed for
rewards
collectibles
you checked your window what about these
representations of things
fans love today
i'm
i got checking the demo i'm good
hey rtg studio i'm good and i have more
good news playstation is lit will begin
to roll out in some regions in asia
starting in late
september in the weekend
i would just turn up from the zoom deck
a little bit king i was trying i was
asking y'all oh yeah his um what what's
your pod track maybe his paw track yeah
turn this point
cut it up to eight yeah cause it's it's
pretty your pod track i didn't think
about that
that's where the majority of the oh it's
calling me from
[Music]
so how's that yeah that's better yeah
there you go not actual gameplay don't
you love when they say that like set
adventures
yeah all the same god of war
man
this looks magnificent but it ain't got
a wall
you cutting that out
my favorite fighting game already one of
my favorite favorite games of all time
i bought a playstation strictly for tech
tekken
look at this world oh my god
he says i got a steam deck i was playing
it a lot 60 frames in um the resolution
on the screen
yeah for me i'm lit i got tekken 8 like
a dragon and demio i think you stopped
the show for me
[Music]
[Music]
no but i feel i feel funny and all this
stuff he ain't really feeling it
these next two intense action games
so exclusive hold on to your butts
who are you mad today
oh boy
[Music]
yeah it is it is it's very very
intrusive the world is going to burn
today what is this shift up second
yes
[Music]
i remember that girl horse
[Music]
no no that's that suit is dope
honey i remember this
they showed this before you know
i remember her outfit you don't remember
it was uh one of the earlier first trip
i'm telling you man you just got a bad
memory
no i just don't remember this no no not
talking about you
yeah this is jizz this is it she got a
jacket on this time
yeah i'm about this
say you don't want to give us bayonetta
i think he is right i think yeah
i think we do it oh
way better now too yeah
project he didn't look at enticing last
time
[Music]
it looked good to me i was just waiting
for more of it and then they hashtag
just one bag
look at that
she said get up out of here
[Music]
somebody give me
[Music]
[Music]
oh
yeah he gonna flip after this because
when they say thank you for coming out
good night
yeah i said he gonna travel down for 70.
oh team ninja oh
after this for everybody though oh
no this
this is probably no
neo3
i still don't understand why they
haven't liked us
this is a good studio man someone needs
to snatch this studio
oh yeah
they taking
i can't help the streams lagging guys i
don't know what's going on
your
oh something scooping dudes and he's
smaller
let's get it console exclusive
on pc let's get it
[Laughter]
rise of the ronin experience an era of
great change and upheaval in rise of the
ronin a sprawling action rpg from team
ninja
uh-oh
before we wrap up oh here we go one more
update playstation studios
2023 here we go yo that's it not actual
gameplay on the bottom what's that about
i know
shout out to the cgi
get the new controller
[Laughter]
pack them up
it's been spooky for him it's been
spooky foreign
oh
oh
you know this whole game we've never
known what the whole goal of this game
they're looking for kings need you to
trust me
they ain't gonna find them until 2023.
you don't believe in any of them
they didn't find them because i already
got this
thank you
guys who's keeping you safe
just
it's looking really
you're gonna you're gonna need that
tungsten you can hopefully walk a little
bit you gotta put it you got to wrap
that tongue around if i got a wheelchair
i'll be there
i'll be your huckleberry
that's when they're closing up on them
what's that that's the eclipse till next
year
shoot it out the chest
see you next year
that's necessary
they got the avatar people
grandiose
my man this is one hell of a trailer i'm
not gonna lie yeah
that's what i'm talking about this is
the trail of all trailers trailer we
make our own destiny big one
that's the
door though
me
other than that all you got is a nice
good trailer
i look crazy they look fantastic they
say elder rick not in trouble
what they say what they say is y'all you
know what i'm saying look it's sick
game's gonna have to be magnificent to
beat eldon ring like it really is oh
brandon rider with casey pre-order don't
mean nothing but don't you other people
say king knees in bed well you know the
best thing about that is you get to
choose a side
if you choose against me boy the odds of
you winning is very slim
[Laughter]
but again i i do say this
this is one of a better state of place
this was fantastic yeah i'm biased as
hell yeah i don't y'all just just get me
well i know this is the greatest thing
i know well the stuff that i missed in
the beginning and from here and you talk
about it it was some good stuff but when
i got in there and i saw that um kita
blade or whatever is that the whole
thing
yeah it's only like 20 minutes
yeah that's it um
they don't need to do nothing else they
needed to do that for me
they needed to tell me to shut up
because i was i'm feeling away man i it
was lit but man it was so lit i wanted
more i want more yeah
no you know i like it like that pulse
just get in hit hard and let it be what
that was good man that was good that
that was a nine out of ten right there
that was a nine out of ten i'd give it a
10 out of 10.
that was a nine out of ten and i'll give
it a 10 out of 10 because it did exactly
what i said it was going to do first of
all it fooled the hell out of me with
the controller right yes stay full i was
like yeah i busted early i bust waiters
yeah
that that was a phenomenal event yeah
and they they kept they kept it they
kept the pace
they hit hard and they going into the
holiday season
you know you know striking when i is hot
so that's what's up
that is what's up 10 out of 10. yeah
they did that they were stroll strolling
nine even the little smaller joints they
didn't spend too long with them got into
team ninja with the two exclusive joints
i mean to bring you one exclusive than
that other was it project eve a little
bit more better on that bro tekken oh
listen let's go i just need to do
specifics on consoles i gotta see it
earl i gotta watch it again now i'm
gonna keep it real though i gotta i
gotta stand tall on the game
they they see g.i the hell out of that
out of tekken yeah like bro that's not i
mean don't get me wrong that's probably
with the end game yeah you know i won
the energy ball i will say one thing
though
i will say one thing when it comes to
fighters i don't play them but generally
what the game looks like in cgi is
generally what the game
looks like
when you see this giant i was just like
yeah
remember i wouldn't know what it is
let's give credit where credit is due
nintendo and playstation killed it today
i didn't see
a lot of people don't like nintendo's
but i like nintendo's to screw them
like
i like the reports that i was getting
from it
yeah i i just liked it because they
showed me what i want and i don't care
what you got no that's that's
same thing for me the show was over they
didn't even show god award the first
three times like bang bang [ __ ] shut up
let's go it was just like
yo man i'm gonna be real that was a
great show
that's why i said it was so good i was
like man
where's moore
no i i see it was those people man you
you can't please this dude yeah i
literally gave it a nine out of ten i
was saying it was so good like i i i
dropped off no more food
i don't ask if you're excited for pikmin
4.
[Laughter]
no i look pikmin didn't really like get
this
like adequate nintendo had a lot of
stuff that applied to me just because
you guys didn't like it don't mean i
don't have to like actually
what what did you give a nintendo show
yeah what'd you get it was an eight out
of ten it was a good show
how come nobody could please you
and stuff like that like that that don't
apply to me like almost every game that
was shown besides vr
was lit so let me tell you this since i
said a little bit less vr would be a 10
out of 10.
and when i say a little bit less vr me
no vr it's the best thing that they've
had in a while because they've seen the
taste been a little little shaky i feel
like for me
hold on hold on let's get lost sovereign
real quick
when literally goes to shima's story is
about the transition of someone from
samurai ninja so you can't it really is
it's about someone's internal struggle
struggle going from one to the other
story
he was a ninja and he was a samurai in
that the way the samurai was dying and
they had he had a transition because
exactly because everything was falling
apart alright yeah they want to keep her
honorable and they out there getting
slaughtered in the street he's like no
we're going to do this
that was a that was one of the best
playstation 4 exclusives that was one of
the best places somebody asked though
why why they getting the team didn't you
get the exclusive yeah because they paid
the money wow
i'm gonna be real with you i'm gonna be
right like people ain't gonna like
i'm about i'm about
i i ain't being kind to xbox this sunday
like uh i'm not happy with full facebook
i'm not happy we're gonna have to see
what happens with this tgs because uh
there's a lot of things that's happening
there's a lot of things that happen
today that
fire
i got a cannon and i'm gonna shoot it
sunday don't please listen what i'm
saying hold your kid i heard some things
man i have a cannon and i'm gonna shoot
it if i don't like what i see i don't
know i got it
with whatever microsoft is doing i like
sony finally getting me to put up my box
so
now can you unlock your account and play
it play your play yeah well uh first of
all i think i think that's over so can
be honest with you i think i'm just
gonna have to have a whole new name and
just start it off and then start from
ground zero with these dudes again yes
and it's it's it's disgusting that their
level of customer service is disgusting
it's bad i had a friend and i lost him i
had a friend over he had like a thousand
dollars plus worth of uh like cells and
stuff uh from where he's bought stuff
from like the whole ps3 generation
for two games
you know and i want my name xbox 360
level one and they're not trying to get
it up so again i know it is it's going
to be like the xbox one level no it's
not they're not going to let me put xbox
nothing
they're going to say invalid and you can
pick them up
we good on this man what's what's
everyone's writing man like uh
caught mine's nine out of ten now you
had a solid show probably their best
i think that might be their best day to
play like that literally might be the
ground running no fill-up thing great
games thank you vr showcase demo one of
the biggest hottest joys they did that
they did that and then you ended with
god of war what people wanted to see you
know what i'm saying fantastic and the
controller
so of course he's a fake ninja saw he's
a samurai what the hell is wrong with
you did you you didn't play the game i'm
now convinced i'm gonna play the game
song i i think you'll see more of him
being like
like a true ninja in the sequel because
this game was about the transition not
him being a ninja it was about him using
ninja turtles how are you talking about
what exactly went on today
they got this fake rivalry going on with
the
presidio ninjas and we just literally i
for sure i'm gonna need the chat to put
what you guys think that uh that was so
suicide he said six out of 10.
shout out to stephanie the sales
solution from haiti oh southpaw
anybody that gave that joint less than
an eight go ahead with yourself mm-hmm
and i'm gonna say
this oh
they said you would saw a fight i'm
talking seven yeah
stuff that we do we do that instead of
playing with average like ghost [ __ ] wow
wow
average wow i i i think i said this look
at y'all hate it
you know what man you know what solvent
and cog would you be open to showing
that stream
yeah any time we will jump into that
this sunday
this sunday what we doing like that will
be the next little well i'm trying to
make people do the show and then they do
the show no i'm not no i'm not
can you can you let me finish you guys
please yes yes this sunday man we we get
we get i would say
we get 10 members
10 members this sunday and we'll we'll
schedule a date for them to fight oh
yeah schedule i thought you would do a
back to back no no i was like yo
here's my new thing man people be
demanding stuff i gotta see that that
that back end support man you guys want
extra we need a little action
because here's the thing man
i might have to record it so i have to
take time out of my time they got to re
they got a place they got to take time
out of daytime jd so we're getting
scheduled man we're getting scheduled
this sunday 10 members that and i only
feel like that's a lot 10 members and
we'll do or 10 members of merchandise
one of the others 10 members or
merchandise and then you'll have lower
cognito and lord sovereign fighting to
the death in tekken 7.
god wants you to makes better it was
average at best six and a half no hating
wow okay
our eight out of ten no doubt seven out
of ten six of 20 24 is false
somebody said that who coming out in
2024 the team ninja stuff that's what
that was for yeah okay one of watch your
trailers in 4k later yeah you know they
liked it though overalls because five
out of 10 damn it took them one year to
show 20 minutes
550 bucks for a position bob and all
they have is 20 minutes gotta want lit
though
isn't the tokyo game show this um yeah
that's what's friday stop hold your
horses before you bust the shots at
certain console platforms
i told you like see here's the thing the
good thing for them
is they got this whole weekend to settle
my issues they got the whole weekend
tokyo game show xbox is there you know
what i'm being told they they showing
showing up this year they ain't just
showing up so we'll see because
octopath travel 2 not coming to xbox
after we just got the original one in
game pass i got issues and i'm i'm going
to talk my talk sunday so we'll see
we'll see what happens you got microsoft
you got till sunday
it'll please me you can see my eyes
rolling behind me why why you got to
fold your horse
[Music]
you're ridiculous anyway sinister give
it an hour to debrief from the hype uh
stitch oh shout out to my man ducky
ain't nothing wrong with that say king
david when you're gonna get your king's
forklift yeah ducky gotcha he's trying
to get you that clip well ducky don't
got me cause ducky wasn't my friend oh
so so so i had to go add ducky since we
want to call people off no no he said he
was gonna help you yeah he was gonna
help me but you had to say that there
since i added you as my friend you can
actually text me now oh that's true
all right so and it wasn't like we
wasn't playing before
together can be unique gaming five
dollar super chat i have to ask why do
people pre-order digital games
especially the ps4 games yeah just wait
till that day
yeah um i'm bi
i'm a little bit i get i'm about but
like at this point don't buy a game
unless it's like like a couple days
before long enough for you to pre-order
it like pre-load it like
especially people with slow internets
don't do that more than a day or two
before because at this point you give
them the money yeah you no any money
microsoft sony playstation any publisher
i don't care who it is don't give them
your money until a couple days before it
comes out obviously you can do what you
want but that's just microsoft they give
you money back
yeah yeah
that is a good point two dollar
superchat from lloyd metro tears of the
tears of the kingdom is game of the year
2023 calling it now you know 2023 is is
looking like to be a fantastic year
might be one of the best years of gaming
you got that star filled
maybe hellblade 2
[Music]
you know
i'm sure sony going to be there somehow
somewhat there's going to be something
there
apparently my super chat doesn't count
i'm confused
i read it i read it
larry metro we missed lauren that's
right no i i read lord metroid that he
said lord metro with the two dollars
tears of the kingdom is game of the year
2023 he's calling now
i don't know about all that
salute
yeah lords of the kingdom look pretty
good i don't know about that performance
though i don't know about that
performance oh you know about it
and then um
we got a new
[Music]
a new uh what's that franchise called
that nintendo owns man
um
red emblem new red emblem coming out
fire emblem fire do fire oh yeah i
missed that i missed that yeah fire
emblem yeah i think it's in february
next year is being really real next year
is crazy yeah it's really rough yeah god
of war all that stuff coming out next
year is fantastic all right out of the
ring might have some competition for
good over the year
checking this out for the next j grudge
spider-man 2 20 23. i could see it
coming out in 2023 but i would look more
for 2024 release date on spider-man 2. i
i feel like you know that that's the
biggest things that they got is they
announce a game
and i feel like sony has no problem
announcing a game and delaying it
they just they have no problem doing
that uh but they've already delayed god
of war so i don't i don't see that
happening i hope it does happen so uh
you know king can get his little w but i
doubt it two dollars super traffic from
flame three out of ten show wanted jim
to dance on a pile
money that seems like pretty high
i
of
expectation is it your money he's going
to jump on
you're going to do that for that ten
dollars he charges you all extra bucks
say you know i guess we could go ahead
and wrap this up so you know
first off we got a lot of stuff
we got some new merch coming from you
guys eventually you know you have to
give us a little bit of time
uh we got some news new stuff man we got
a lot of new stuff and like i said
everyone in the chat this sunday we get
10 members or 10
merchandise one of the other
cognito and sovereign
speakers
got some new tech and details shout out
to nineveh all right so take it eight
deals details from harada trailer takes
place during the story mode of the guy
new as a trailer i knew that oh wait oh
ho no sorry take it back i was wrong
all real-time footage running at 60
frames per second dynamic backgrounds
with unique stage effects story will
focus on kazuya versus gin still in
development oh let's go so that's unreal
from stitch 669 god of war dlc not
beating elden ring definitely
possibility man definitely possibility i
could totally see that being an issue in
that but you know uh one thing i want to
bring up is though i am applying for a
fortnight content creator apparently you
have to be like an epic content creator
to be able to do custom lobbies i am
applying for that and uh we uh you what
we can do is hopefully we can squat up
me cognito key and solve and you guys
will hunt us
get
hunted
yeah cause we actually you know i
haven't seen [ __ ] play that but me me
and king are pretty nice on support
exactly
it's not gonna be that easy to kill us
but it's gonna be interesting i'm sure
there are people in the chat that are
better but i'm gonna say we gonna bring
it you know it's gonna be you ain't
taking it we're gonna breathe
i doubt it
but i appreciate every coming through
man uh we will see you this sunday at 1
p.m unless something else happens no we
will not be streaming the tokyo game
show that's at like six in the morning
that's in the bushes uh but we will be
sunday to talk about
the tokyo game
i'm gonna wake up and watch it but we'll
be there sunday to talk about the tokyo
game show and uh appreciate everyone for
coming through but we're gonna we're
gonna clock out